hello and welcome to video playing and
Julian auction the attack GM that's a
very fitting name okay what you see him
playing I have no idea and probably the
cop of him wow it looks funny
can also go here it
and win Tempe with you 392 later
hmm we should before that's a funny move
definitely not something that I looked
dead when I when I was working on that
video series okay um also thinking
Knight f3 could be interesting here
directly looking at it okay maybe you
can move it maybe you can just move it
back like Bishop Bishop be six or
something Wow why does that work take
stakes be sure before what's the deal
Queen to e7 something maybe I can also
start with this move really a little bit
mystified him
check okay yeah I can take it with this
also d3 and things like that a tikati
does have some compensation on the light
squares that's absolutely clear okay
let's take it i also have Queens a form
which is interesting but maybe you just
move the king ok so I'll take it
yeah I wondered about this bishop I
think this is probably the way to go
I was thinking that it could be an idea
to just put this bishop on the long
diagonal and then just yeah you know i'm
i'm actually not unhappy about this okay
Bishop g4 Queenie 425 could be an issue
which 125 okay so we should be to Bishop
g4 I can go crazy for deform now what
happens a queen f 425f or it's not at
all clear Queen f25 f3 no doesn't work I
can go Queenie form it was my original
intention but was just reconsidering
okay I didn't see that one but ok what's
what's happened what happened Sam
this Queenie five is that what he wants
to play there okay so I rupee for is
also possible well now it's so
interesting for interesting game
Queen f4 would be cool to get d three
rupees three
always be cautious here if you don't
know Julian Hodgson by the way he was a
very strong Grandmaster 26 something
with was I mean he's currently I'm not
actively playing so this is like from
the late 90s or 2000 was extremely
creative and dangerous attacking players
so it's always an absolutely interesting
experience to play against am here on
the ICC don't he doesn't play all that
frequently but as I said it's always
interesting looking five you might take
on edge for okay look II five I don't
think I can afford efore you maybe I can
tie morning you know this is the main
thing
I have absolutely no time here don't
don't even know what took me so long in
this game the opening everything that I
don't know and probably this makes the
objective merits of the positioning
unimportant I really don't know what's
going on in might be that he has has
some dangerous attack for rookie to hear
so on let's get let's get I can take
only for him
you should be full okay wanna maybe
still some kind of game I'm reasonably
sure that this position wasn't all that
bad at the beginning check okay three
maybe my group g3 wins no I cannot
advocate for actually it might win but
Jack maybe this oh that's cool that's a
cool move yeah okay white resigns ah bad
Rania then run the last couple of games
okay but should deform gym so he just
blinded the porn him basically but it
wasn't all that clear it really wasn't
all that clear the engine wants to do
this actually it makes an awful lot of
sense once you look at it yes yes some
problems if he takes this then I'm
threatening Queen 84 which is really bad
as if i was hanging as well and if you
take see a queen bee three years
fantastic for white I am Bishop g5 the
better development to bishops blah blah
blah and this said this does window porn
but check
it is not easy to handle so we have this
gym I wanted to do this but I thought
you can take here or of course not I can
just take this it's a checkmate on g7
yeah then clean air for is just good of
course this is what the engine wants to
play okay you will get this back so this
is also just equal now yes definite
compensation yeah and the position is
extremely extremely murky rook c8 so
it's hard to say when it is when it
starts to become bad for me yeah if what
is probably a problem mistake you also
has f5 I could I couldn't really figure
out this position it's just very very
weird this is the engines move
it's a very human eye on him it's
impossible to really figure out Tim
that's a strong move of course I cannot
take check and the sisters work I mean I
was just trying to check hang on somehow
but it didn't work so the real deal here
is the opening after I mean first I
thought I can just change the scrap like
this but here he has stuff Bishop g4 or
something like that but this is
extremely a d3 is extremely strong I
mean it's very unlikely that i have
again this precise position again but
this is just a lot stronger than he 3
sometimes this is a problem you know you
see you win a pawn and you kind of see
that I mean I was pretty it was clear to
me this isn't all that easy but you
still think okay well he is his blunder
this basically take the pawn but it is
not it's not that that grade I mean
generally isn't and if you look for
alternatives and your CD 3 once you get
this this move on your radar you see how
strong it is he also has to face this
threat so he cannot just I mean he has
to take on d3 and out of this
supposition is really rubbish he has to
go back and then I don't know before
Bishop b2 assess this is terrible so
that's very interesting and don't try to
play the first move that wins material
does still look for alternatives which
is difficult of course in blitz games
but this is something form like in a
real tournament game you definitely
shouldn't grab the pawn to Utley but
check for alternatives because what
black is Dahlia in the open
we cannot cannot be all that gradient
move the bishop here again and that we
get it he allow me to take it giving up
the two bishops and d3 is just an
enormously strong in comparison they are
very unlikely let up get it again but
but still itself it's a good reminder
that you should not take the first pole
and offer to you especially if you
recognize that it's just not flat porn
but kind of kind of interested or kind
of unclear to have this pawn okay thanks
for watching